bonjour Monsieur Alain beer professeur
de criminologie au Conservatoire
national des arts et métiers responsable
scientifique du pôle sécurité défense
renseignement criminologie cybermenace
et crise vous avez
accepté de venir devant notre commission
d'enquête sur l'impact du narcotrafic en
France et les mesures à prendre pour y
remédier et je vais comme il est d'usage
euh vous rappelez qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
possible des peines prévues aux articles
4 4- 13-1- 15 du code pénal et je vais
vous inviter à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure merci donc ce que je vous propose
avec le micro je le jure très bien ce
que je vous propose si vous en êtes
d'accord c'est de faire peut-être un
petit une petite présentation liminaire
à la suite de laquelle nous échangerons
avec le rapporteur Étienne blanc en vous
posant des question je merci ben écoutez
merci de votre
invitation il est toujours intéressant
de revenir dans cette maison parler de
la problématique du trafic de stupéfiant
puisque au moment où l'État en France
était le principal dealer public du pays
avec la régie française de l'opium qui
était la version Seita des stupes au
moment où dans nos territoires coloniaux
le chemin de fer de l'Indochine allait
de champ depavau en champ de pavo c'est
dans cette maison que les parlementaires
radicaux et médecins de toutes origines
et de toutes diance ont décidé de mettre
en cause la pratique qui visait à faire
de l'argent sur le trafic des
stupéfiants au nom de problématiques de
santé publique et de médecine je vous
renvoie tout ceci au dragon domestique
de feu mon collègue Christian Bachman
qui est l'ouvrage le plus abouti et
hélas inabouti du fait de sa
disparition sur l'historique de la
manière dont la problématique des
stupéfiant a d'abord été considéré comme
un outil naturel de développement de
business et de de commerce et pour tous
ceux qui ont vu les 55 jours de Pékin je
voudrais le rappeler qu'il s'agit d'une
œuvre de pure fiction et que la première
coalition internationale de l'histoire
du monde entre des pays qui ne s'étaient
jamais fait que la guerre avant et après
a eu lieu pour imposer à l'Empire du
Milieu la fin de la prohibition contre
le trafic et la consommation des
stupéfiants au bénéfice de l'ensemble
des puissances coalisées qui allaient
des États-Unis au Japon en passant par
la France la Grande-Bretagne l'Allemagne
et quelques autres donc nous avons une
vision aujourd'hui du problème des
stupéfiants qui est une vision pénale il
y a un peu plus de 100 ans c'était fort
heureusement une vision médicale et elle
répondait à plusieurs problématiques un
l'addiction et une addiction massive sur
des populations nombreuses dont une très
grande partie avait été gazé dans les
tranchées en 1418 le préfet de police
expliquait qu'il y avait avait 100000
addictés aux stupéfiants à Paris en 1920
et que c'était un problème majeur qu'il
fallait avoir tra qu'il faudrait traiter
une bonne fois pour toutes et il se
trouve qu'à l'époque les stupéfiants
étit un médicament utilisé pour et si le
Coca-Cola s'appelle coca c'est pas juste
pour faire plaisir c'est parce que
l'essentiel de son de sa composition
comme le vin Mariani qui fut son ancêtre
et dont le brevet a été volé par les
Américains au détr des Français était un
produit purement stopifiant basé sur la
cocaïne alors certes pas exactement
traitée comme celle qui est vendue
actuellement mais qui avait
effectivement des effets dit bénéfiques
pour toute une série d'activités
notamment de haute intensité
ou de ou dans ou en altitude nous avons
une relation donc avec les stupéfiant
beaucoup plus complexe beaucoup plus
difficile à traité et beaucoup plus
incompréhensible que celle que nous
avons depuis la loi de
1970 qui qui a totalement modifié
l'approche de la question des
stupéfiants en France pour des raisons
pénales alors que jusque-là la question
médicale avait été considéré comme
essentiel nous avons donc eu des phases
de traitement de la gestion des
stupéfiants là je parle de la
consommation accessoirement de la
production et de l'Exportation puis du
trafic qui ont amené à des modifications
majeures d'approche donc de culture une
culture médicale puis une culture pénale
pour répondre à un un ultimatum
américain du président Nixon euh qui
impliquait que nous arrêtions de
submerger les États-Unis de production
de très bonne qualité mais qui posait
unun certain nombre de gros problèmes ce
qui explique d'ailleurs l'apparition du
narcotiques bureau enensite de laadea à
Marseille et donc si vous voulez avoir
une idée à peu près précise de
l'évolution du temps avec des
docufections qui n'avaient pas encore ce
nom et bien vous regardez borsalino enco
pour comprendre ce qui a été carbone et
Spirito s'imposant euh et créant le
premier kist criminel français à
Marseille et puis la French Connection
expliquant ce qu' a été la
l'industrialisation du trafic et
l'effet imprévu secondaire pervers de la
loi de 1970 qui ne sachant pas faire le
tri entre consommateur consommateur
dealer et gros trfrican a créé un peu
comme notre code pénal d'ailleurs une
idée qu'il fallait tout réprimer de la
même manière et donc prison pour tout et
pour tous ça ne marche pas donc nous
sommes dans un processus sans aucun sens
sans aucune cohérence et où nous
traitons en permanence de conséquences
liées à des injonctions contradictoire
qui n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'une mise
à plat par le gouvernement alors même je
tiens à le souligner que les assemblées
et notamment l'Assemblée nationale
l'année dernière a réussi d'une manière
assez intelligente à avoir un dialogue
construit intelligible cohérent sur la
question de la gestion de la
problématique des subvivants le fait de
savoir si on est d'accord ou pas avec
les conclusions est une autre affaire je
précise simplement que le débat a eu
lieu qu'il a abouti à une forme de mise
en cohérence de la manière don on
pouveit aborder la question et d'un
certain nombre d'outils proposant de les
traiter alors je le précise bien moi je
suis contre toutes les adhctions donc
j'apparais plutôt comme un répressif
mais quand une politique de prohibition
donne des résultats aussi inverses à
toute politique de prohibition qui a eu
lieu dans l'histoire qu'elle soit celle
de l'alcool ou les autres nous avons un
souci quant à la cohérence de la
politique un une politique de
prohibition ça se traduit par une
raréfaction du produit une baisse de la
qualité et une augmentation du prix en
France nous avons exactement l'inverse
une augmentation de la qualité une
augmentation de la quantité et une
baisse des prix il y a quand même un
sujet et quand une politique de
prohibition abouti à l'effet économique
exactement inverse à celui recherché
c'est donc que la politique est mauvaise
ou qu'elle est mal appliquée en France
c'est les deux la politique est mauvaise
parce qu'elle est incohérente et elle
est mal appliquée parce que bien
évidemment avec le nombre de
consommateurs que nous avons le nombre
de consommateurs réguliers que nous
avons le nombre de jeunes consommateurs
que nous avons et le changement de la
nature des produits par une augmentation
massive du taux de
THC dans les produits de type
cannabisoïde l'arrivée de produits de
synthèse dont certains sont
extraordinairement dangereux nitazè
kétamine et autres produits de
fabrication de dans son arrière cuisine
ou dans son labo la CAPAC C désormais
avoir des relations directes du
producteur au consommateur par la
surmultiplication des champs de
production ou des petits labos chimiques
à petit à petitte zone de chalandise le
développement massif de la consommation
dans des zones qui sont passées de la
banlieu à l'aglo et de l'aglo à la
petite ou à la moyenne ville tous ces
éléments là accumulés montrent que la
politique s'il y en avait une de lutte
contre les stupéfiants est un échec
conceptuel structurel et opérationnel
donc il y a un souci générique qui
nécessite de reprendre le problème
depuis le début un qui consomme de
pourquoi on consomme 3 comment on
consomme qu'est-ce qu'on consomme et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
reprendre la problématique d'abord
médicale qui est paradoxalement la plus
simple par la désaddiction y compris par
des mesures fermes de des addictions
jusqu'à la politique de lutte contre les
grands trafiquants et not notamment sur
un certain nombre
d'espaces qui nous sont proches et qui
sont des paradis fiscaux ou des
blanchisseuses bien connus des produits
stupéfiants y compris des endroits où on
retrouve beaucoup d'influenceurs
euh qui ont basé leur leur arrière-cours
voilà nous avons ça comme problématique
générale le reste est bien connu l'OFDT
comme l'EDT font très bien leur travail
les problématiques de de connaissance et
des substances et de l'évolution des
substances des zones de développement
des substances de la quantité de
personnes incriminées de l'augmentation
relativement
forte des ce qu'on appelait overdose ou
surdose en français l'arrivée rapide et
attendue d'un côté du captagon et de
l'autre du fintanil vont nous amener à
des problématiques médicamenteuses
encore pire que celles qui ont pu être
connues dans des problématique
récente sur le détournement du
médicament je pense au médiator en
particulier mais n'était qu'un
épiphénomène par rapport à ce qui est
face à nous le fait que nous soyons
désormais entourés par deux voire trois
narco-états Belgique Pays-Bas il déteste
quand on dit ça mais c'est quand même
comme ça que c'est du point de vue
policier en tout cas et même du point de
vue des magistrats qui nous qui qui
n'hésite plus à dire les choses la
situation de notre frontière avec
l'Espagne est extrêmement
préoccupante les problématiques
guyanais atteignent des degrés
absolument invrais semblable à la fois
d'acceptation de l'ampleur du trafic
hein puisque désormais une circulaire
pénale avait même prévu qu'en dessous
d'un kil on poursuivait plus qui est
inattendu j'avais vu jusqu'à 100 g alors
je je dois dire très honnêtement que le
niveau en gramage de ce qui était
poursuivable ou pas était une nouveauté
je n'avais pas vu que le parlementaire
avait été aussi précis je crois qu'il
avait provoqué une sorte d'interdit
absolue mais bon on s'adapte comme on
peut euh mais là on a face à ce
département en particulier une
problématique particulière et
extrêmement inquiétante de la même
manière que sur le craque on a des
situations dans les domes tout à fait
inquiétante avec un développement assez
important et des espaces qui sont plutôt
limités sur le territoire métropolitain
Stalingrad et cetera mais
extraordinairement développé dans
d'autres espaces qui doivent être
considérés comme la métropole entre
guillemets puisqu'ils appartiennent au
territoire national donc une situation
générale de de dégradation une
problématique d'augmentation de la
consommation de contournement
d'augmentation de l'intensité des
produits
consommés et face à cela des postures
des mouvements des tours de bras des
déclarations des sommations assez peu de
réflexion assez peu de de contenu et une
incohérence absolue entre la
proclamation l'action
l'accompagnement et donc un saupoudrage
généralisé qui amène mécaniquement à à
force de vouloir tout faire sans rien
vraiment faire de ne pas savoir
exactement ce qu'on fait donc de ne pas
répondre à la à la problématique ni de
l'expansion du trafic ni de son
intensification ni l'augmentation des
règlements de compte particulièrement
développé spécifiquement à Marseille
mais c'est une tradition mais quand on
parle beaucoup de Marseille on oublie de
parler de ce qui se passe autour de
Montpellier autour de Grenoble un peu
autour de Toulouse évidemment à Sevran
et dans la banlieu
parisienne à Valence donc j'ai découvert
moi-même hein que c'était une ville qui
aujourd'hui avait basculé de l'autre
côté du miroir avec des listes de gens à
éliminer des problématiques inédites
dans la manière dont on s'exprime sur la
question et comme nos amis trafiant ont
pris l'habitude de nous raconter sur
Youtube ou TikTok à peu près tout ce
qu'ils veulent faire fond ou devrai
faire il faut pas sous-estimer au-delà
du matamorisme ambiant euh une
problématique de dégradation forte je
veux dire même de désagrégation euh de
la des effets euh de euh la logique des
stupéfiants et donc de ces effets aussi
en terme de violence de mortalité
d'enlèvement de torture de barbaries
diverses euh qui amène il suffit d'aller
dans les tribunaux et pas seulement à
bobini pour se rendre compte de ce
qu'est l'apparition d'un état parallèle
qui est un état narco même si la France
n'est pas encore un
narco-état voilà si vous vouliez une
option optimiste n'était pas moi qu'il
fallait inviter en ce début d'année tu
pas optimiste mais c'est stimulant du
coup Étienne blanc va rebondir merci
beaucoup est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler un petit peu cette loi de 70
les conditions dans lesquelles elle a
été adoptée les raisons pour lesquel il
a été et l'influence des États-Unis ah
ben c'est un coup de téléphone du
président Nixon au président de la
République qui lui a dit il en a marre
donc si vous ne prenez pas des mesures
pour démanteler les labos les réseaux et
la distribution il y a eu une affaire
majeure qui était l'affaire je vais pas
dire une bêtise mais angelevin je crois
un présentateur de télévision qui avait
caché dans vous avez la version drôle
dans le
corniot voilà tout ça est une histoire
vraie alors drôle dans le corniot et pas
drôle du tout du d'américain qui décide
de faire la lutte à la drogue les
Américains font la guerre à à peu près
tout alors ils la font plus ou moins
bien euh au terrorisme quand il faut la
faire là ils ont décidé de faire la
guerre à la drogue parce que la
diffusion des produits stupéfiants de
très haute qualité produit par les labos
corsau marseillais français avait amené
à submerger le marché américain et donc
pour des raisons légitimes qui est de
lutter contre le trafic et lutter contre
les effets du trafic hein parce que la
la pureté des produits amenait
évidemment déjà un début d'overdose ou
de surdose considérable donc des raisons
médicales en France sont amené à une
politique visant à lutter contre les
addictions et pas à lutter contre le
trafic ce qui avait donné de meilleurs
résultats et par ailleurs prenez en
compte le problème des gazages dans les
tranchées qui est un sujet qu'il faut
prendre en considération on ne savait
pas comment traiter euh voilà et puis
c'est je veux dire les stupéfiants le
cannabis ou le reste ça a des effets
médicaux qu'il faut pas du tout
sous-estimer le problème c'est que nous
faisons tout trop euh la France aime les
extrêmes c'est soit tout soit rien et
donc euh on n'a pas pris en compte les
dimensions médicales et utiles de toute
une série de médicaments dont certains
sont liés aux produits stupéfiants les
opiacés sont des produits médicaux comme
d'autres euh mais au lieu de traiter de
la question d'un point de vue médical le
le coup de téléphone du président Nixon
a amené un bouleversement dans la
politique française et la loi de 1970
qui est apparue sur injonction
américaines pour des raisons de
politique intérieure de de lutte contre
les stupéfiant et d'absence totale
d'action de la France qui considérait
que si on pouvait les exporter c'était
pas très grave c'est un peu comme les
Anglais avec le Londonistan tant que les
terroristes djihadistes qui étaient à
Londres commettaient des attentats hors
d'Angleterre on s'en occupait pas il y
avait une sorte de de nit de d
d'ailleurs le refus d'extrader l'un des
principaux financiers du terrorisme
international pendant des années' n'a
débouché qu'après que des attentats aent
eu lieu à Londres et où les Anglais
considéraent que bon bah puisque c'était
comme ça on pouvait faire de la
coopération internationale puisqu'on
nétait plus immune d'une activité
intérieure voilà c'est problèmes
habituels on l'a vu avec le TA entre les
Espagnols et l'arrière basse français
donc ce sont des sujets récurrents le
président Nixon a demandé c'est une
injonction elle est connue elle a été
détaillée d'ailleurs dans certain nombre
d'ouvrages sur les relations
franco-américaines et donc nous avons
produit une loi écrite avec les pieds
d'urgence n'importe comment qui est la
loi de 1970 qui malheureusement ne
traite pas de manière différenciée des
problématiques différentes une
problématique d'addiction qui est une
problématique médicale et qui doit se
traiter par de manières médicale une
problématique de dealer consommateur
mais de petite envergure qui en fait fa
produit pour lui-même
et se paye pour d'autres et qu'il faut
traiter avec je dirais une sorte
d'aménagement parce que c'est pas Pablo
Escobar et puis Pablo Escobar qu'il faut
traiter comme Pablo Escobar loi de 70
elle traite tout le monde de la même
manière dans son intention évidemment
dans son application c'est impossible
quand on arrête 60 80 100000
consommateurs pour faire du chiffre on
les renvoie pas tous devant les
juridiction parce que ça ne marche pas
donc on fait de l'injonction
thérapeutique faut pas recommencer ou de
de la saisie avec destruction des
éléments par l'usage de la chasse d'eau
voir réutilisation pour les indicateurs
divers et multiple parce que il faut
bien trouver un moyen
de compenser leur activité au bénéfice
de la société bref on a inventé toute
une série de petits aménagements
légitimes et normaux parce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne et la réalité
est la réalité mais on n pas tranché sur
décriminalisations dépénalisations
contraavent naalisation
libéralisation le CBD est-il ou n'est-il
pas et vous voyez d'ailleurs dans les
décisions du Conseil d'État ou de la
Cour de cassation une sorte de grande
incertitude générale sur la
problématique de ce qui peut être
médicalement accepté et de ce qui doit
être pénalement réprimé donc ne sachant
pas faire du surmesure nous avons fait
du prête àorter et donc c'est soit trop
grand soit trop petit mais ça ne taille
jamais juste vous avez parlé de
daddiction comment vous voyez
pratiquement cette une nouvelle
politique sur la désaddiction bah
d'abord l'injonction thérapeutique
pourrait être une vraie injonction
thérapeutique c'estàd une obligation de
soins ceci existe d'ailleurs dans le
code de la santé publique pour toute une
série d'éléments évidemment pour que
quelqu'un se décide la désaddiction il
faut évidemment qu'il fasse partie du
programme mais vous aviez avec le
docteur olivenstein à marmotant des
programmes extrêmement innovants qui
avaient pris en compte les choses mais
qui sont restés des programmes innovant
perdu au milieu de rien qui était une
sorte d'excuse ah ben on a un truc
là-bas évidemment ça ne peut pas traiter
l'ensemble des je sais plus combien 4
millions de ceux qui ont un jour ou
l'autre consommé du 1 million et demi
qui doit le faire plus ou moins
régulièrement évidemment qui ne savent
plus traiter la différence qui existait
entre du THC à 1 et demi 2 et du THC à
15 en en intensité puisque il n'y a plus
de j'ai été auditionné il y a quelques
temps par le Parlement belge et on avait
un débat drogue douce drogue dure alors
j'ai dit d'abord ça existe plus ce
concept a disparu mais en plus ce qu'on
appelait drogue douce avant et qui pose
des tas de problème aux parents des des
années 70 vis-à-vis de leurs enfants par
on peut pas leur expliquer que non j'en
ai pas consommé parce qu'ils en ont tous
consommés ou beaucoup mais qui ne parle
plus du tout du même produit derrière le
mot cannabis et cetera en fait on ne
parle pas du tout de la même substance
et de la
même
intensité de la substance et de ses
effets secondaires donc on a un vrai
souci par rapport à la la capacité de ça
mais moi je crois à l'injonction
thérapeutique une vraie injonction
thérapeutique comme l'élément 1 d'une
politique de santé publique d'une
politique de santé publique qui touche
l'essentiel des personnes qui sont
directement victimes parce que ce sont
des malades et je pense qu'il faut que
nous réintégrions cette dimension à la
suite de quoi il y a une petite partie
de cette population qui sont des
consommateurs dealer c'est qu'il
produisent pour eux consomment mais
revendent et disons qu'il y a là une
adaptation à faire notamment avec les
services de de police mais aussi de
santé publique pour avoir une réponse
mixte qui est liée à la réitérance ou à
la récidive comme dans tout processus
normal de pénalité et puis il y a un
problème de trafiquant majeur et donc au
lieu de continuer à essayer de vider la
mer avec une petite cuillère troué et de
de de d'occuper les forces de police à
des missions qui ne servent à rien dont
il qu'elles ne servent à rien et qui ne
produisent rien les reconcentrer sur on
a le même problème avec la criminalité
ordinaire dans mon métier qui la
criminologie on s'occupe essentiellement
de savoir qui fait quoi 70 % des primos
auteurs ne recommenceront jamais jamais
mais on ne le sait pas la première fois
puisque ils sont primau 30 % vont
recommencer au moins une fois cela il
faut les traiter différemment des
premiers mais déjà dès les premiers il
faut indiquer queil faut s'arrêter il y
a donc un besoin d'expression de
interdit et d'expression rapide de
l'interdit contrairement à une idée
largement répandue les courtes peines ou
les mesures éducative immédiate et
rapide notamment pour les mineurs sont
extrêmement positives elles donnent
d'extraordinaires effets dans les pays
anglo-saxon protestant ou du Nord parce
qu'on intervient vite et on casse le
dispositif rapidement il reste 30 %
c'est 30 % faut les traiter évidemment
avec des mesures renforcées et ensuite
on a environ 5 % qui qui produis 50 % de
l'activité criminelle vous pouvez pas
les traiter comme les 70 autres % ni
même contre les 95 autres
chacun doit être traité en fonction du
niveau de glissement vieillesse
technicité dans l'activité criminelle et
donc faut qu'on s'adapte au mode
opératoire le mode opératoire c'est le
besoin l'envie le plaisir le besoin j'ai
rien et je veux quelque chose alors
c'est un besoin en général utile c'est
celui qui nous a permis de passer du
statut de sujet celui de citoyen c'est
la révolte sociale c'est la révolution
c'est l'expression d'une violence contre
une violence plus grande encore celle-là
elle n'est pas du tout contanable elle
nous a permis d'avoir un parlement une
représentation démocratique des citoyens
voilà parfois c'est excessif parfois
c'est même extrêmement excessif enfin
grosso modo l'histoire a montré plutôt
la légitimité de la révolte et du droit
à la résistance à l'oppression qui est
d'ailleurs dans notre Constitution la
deuxième partie c'est l'envie j'ai envie
d'avoir ce que les ce que quelqu'un a et
n'est pas c'est un effet publicitaire en
général c'est l'effet de la marque c'est
l'effet de la lisibilité de c'est
l'effet des influenceurs c'est l'effet
de l'inutile et du présent mais enfin il
y a en général il y a pas mort d'homme
et puis le troisème élément c'est le
plaisir le plaisir de l'agression de la
possession de la violence sexuelle de la
violence physique de cette augmentation
massive de l'homicides et des
homicidités dont je traite d'ailleurs
dans mon dernier dans mon dernier
bouquin parce que c'est impressionnant
de voir à quel point nous avons inversé
une tendance qui était la réduction à la
violence ultime qui est l'indicateur le
plus stable dans une société l' homicide
le meurtre l'assassinat nous sommes
passés de 150 homicides à moins de 2 en
500 ans c'est un gigantesque succès et
en 20 ans nous avons inverser le
processus quand même un petit quand même
un petit sujet qu'il va falloir traiter
or une partie de cette inversion est
liée au trafic de stup pour les
règlements de compte et à l'augmentation
de la violence physique comme élément de
régulation de la vie parce qu'on ne fait
plus confiance à l'état dans sa capacité
d'être un régulateur un intermédiateur
ou un objet répressif
puisque comme on ne sait pas ce qu'il
fait et que lui-même ne connaît des
injonctions contradictoires ça ne
fonctionne pas donc tout le monde
s'engouffre dans les brèches laissées
par l'État en France puisque l'État en
France il a créé la nation dans tous les
autres pays occidentaux et autres la
nation a créé l'état on a plutôt des
états fédéraux avec c'est le territoire
qui fait la loi et ça en France l'État a
créé la nation l'État est censé tout
faire tout faire à la place de tout le
monde et mieux le faire que les autres
c'était vrai jusque dans les années 70
75 au moment où l'État en France a
décidé de devenir un état libéral au
sens américain ou anglo-saxon du terme
protestant voilà j'ai rien contre mais
c'est un changement de culture d'État et
ce changement de culture il a amené un
dépérissement de l'État y compris sur
ses fondamentaux vous me pardonnerez de
signaler en quelques instants l'état
social l'état médical on l'a vu durant
le covid l'état militaire j'ai
l'impression que nous n'avons plus
vraiment d'armée en tout cas du point de
vue de ceux qui la font hein nous avons
une armée échantillonnaire et
expéditionnaire enfin est pas prête à la
défense opérationnelle du territoire euh
bah l'état sécuritaire une grande
difficulté à gérer le problème des
violences et notamment des violences
physiques un peu partout nous sommes
lyonnais tous les deux je peux vous
faire la liste voilà on lit les mêmes
journaux on voit à peu près ce qui se
passe et cetera et cetera et donc ce
dépérissement de l'État bah il amène à
ce que la nature ay en horreur du vide
euh la violence s'engouffre et notamment
la violence criminelle et la violence
criminelle liée aux stupéfiants qui para
ailleurs un une curiosité en France
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de crime organisé
centralisé depuis Farid berama le
Spartacus des cités et la mort de jeanj
Colona le dernier parrain du crime
organisé français nous avons une
décentralisation par le Kaïa localo
régional donc des frictions des
problématiques de zonees de chalandise
qui sont extrêmement difficiles
Marseille en est l'expression la plus
emblématique mais on peut en parler
aussi à Lyon et dans la banlieue
lyonnaise et même à une
expansion assez forte dans des
territoires euh euh régionaux dont on
n'urait pas l'idée alors je parlais de
Valence tout à l'heure c'est pas la
ville qui vous vient naturellement à
l'esprit mais vous pouvez en choisir
toute une série d'autres et d'ailleurs
la carte des émeutes de ce point de
vue-là a ressemblé d'une manière assez
forte on en parlait encore avec Jérôme
Fourquet il y a quelques quelques
semaines avec la carte du développement
des points de d'Ile la carte des 4000
points de d'Ile elle est très
intéressante parce qu'elle est parfois
extrêmement surprenante euh voilà donc
ce sont ces éléments
qui sont importants et donc la cohérence
d'une politique pour moi pour répondre
définitivement à votre question elle
commence par une politique d'injonction
médicale forte puissante et accompagnée
donc un réinvestissement très puissant
sur la question médicale le
réinvestissement est générique hein mais
celui-là en fait partie deuxièmement une
adaptation aux politiques territoriales
de lutte contre les trafics en intégrant
le fait justement du kaaïda plutôt que
le crime organisé même à Marseille et
puis troisièmement évidemment une un
investissement contre le dealer
trafiquant majeur et surtout le
blanchisseur parce que quand on tape au
fortefeuille c'est encore là que on a
les meilleurs résultats ce que je
vouleis dire c'est que l'amonde
forfaitaire délictuel c'est une vision
répressive et et que sur les
consommateurs ça n'aura pas d'effet bah
déjà faudra que je lis des rapports
extrêmement contradictoires sur
l'utilisation de
la voilà donc déjà c'est une création
douanière AD adap d'une manière plus ou
moins compliquée mais c'est c'est une
réponse immédiate dès lors que un on
paye ce qui est pas garanti et donc si
on paye pas que se passe-t-il
rien parce qu'il ne se passe rien c'est
ça marche pour ceux qui veulent payer
parce que dans l'autre cas on revient au
système ordinaire qui ne sait pas gérer
les 60 80 ou 100000 gus qui sont
interpellés pour consommation donc en
fait la consommation c'est pas un sujet
c'est c'est pas un sujet c'est pas un
sujet P le deal est un sujet pénal pas
la consommation donc il faut arrêter de
s'occuper des consommateurs pour le
gérer d'une autre manière c'est-à-dire
les transférer dans des conditions sur
est-ce qu'on peut vous aider qu'est-ce
qui justifie votre machin en général
d'ailleurs il y a des polyonsommations
qui sont un peu plus compliqué avec
l'alcool et d'autres types de produits
addictifs l' FDT d'ailleurs avait été
créé pour ça he pas de la toxicomanie
mais des toxicomanie on avait eu un
débat extrêmement violent sur le fait de
est-ce qu'on pouvait traiter la drogue
comme le le tabac et l'alcool
mécaniquement oui c'est pas une question
la question c'est de traiter le malade
on s'en fout de savoir de quoi il est
malade si c'est une addiction ça se
traite comme une addiction quelle que
soit l'addiction mais il faut la traiter
pas seulement en parler ni pas seulement
la la
constater voilà l'avantage de l'OFDT
c'est que on travaille beaucoup avec
Michel Gandillon au conservatour des
Arts et Métiers donc c'est un très bon
observateur des problématiques de de
stupéfiant en France et à l'étranger on
s'est rendu compte assez rapidement à la
fois que le territoire de du deal le
développement du deal et les
problématiques du deal était pas des
problèmes de consommateur c'est un
problème de réseau de distribution et
qu'il faut taper le réseau de
distribution sauf que le réseau de
distribution il nimporte de moins en
moins et il autoproduit de plus en plus
je il va y avoir un moment où la France
va devenir exportatrice alors je sais
pas si c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle du point de vue du commerce
extérieur mais en tout cas la capacité
que nous avons à modifier les conditions
dans lesquelles on peut produire une
partie des produits entre guillemets
naturel et de plus en plus produits
chimiques les labos nous ramèneent à
l'avant
1970 bien j'avais une question sur le
dossier coffre une des difficultés que
nous avons repéré aujourd'hui et c'est
la capacité des réseaux puissant
français et internationaux
et
à avec l'intelligence artificielle
notamment comprendre comment les
services de police ont réussis
euh obtenir un certain nombre
d'informations et pour les pour les les
mettre en difficulté et et les juger
et ces élémentsl qui sont des éléments
techniques sont souvent dans le dossier
procédural h par les avocats et par une
étude très précise du dossier on arrive
à sair ce qui s'est passé une des
réponses ça peut-être le dossier COF
c'est-à-dire que l'autorité poursuivante
n'indique pas dans le dossier pénal de
manière transparente
les conditions dans lesquelles les
informations on été recueillies
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous êtes
très attaché à la protection et des
liberté individuelleou moi je suis
attaché à la au fait que la défense
existe et et ce pays qui a beaucoup de
retard du fait du très faible nombre de
ces instructions et du trop grand nombre
de ces enquêtes préliminaires qui
n'offrent aucune garantie sur à peu près
rien et dont la France qui se proclamme
défenseuse des liberté qui n'a même pas
réussi à afficher la bas
corpus toujours pas nous sommes toujours
pas un pays d'Abas corpus 2024 est une
interrogation permanente non je crois
pas que ça soit le le problème d'abord
parce que c'est pas l'intelligence
artificielle qui va résoudre ou ne pas
résoudre les choses l'intelligence
artificielle accélère d'abord elle est
pas intelligente elle est très
artificielle elle le sera un jour mais
c'est pas le cas elle accélère
simplement des processus qui passent
pour l'instant essentiellement par des
informateurs et des indicateurs plus ou
moins payé plus ou moins rémunéré plus
ou moins manipulé et plus ou moins
manipulé ur comme on le voit chaque fois
qu'un policier un douanier ou un
jendarme est mis en cause pour des
livraisons
contrôlées dans des conditions qui ne
satisfont pas toujours à juste titre les
magistrats donc je crois pas que le le
secret de l'instruction final au moment
de la partie je dirais jugement doivent
empêcher l'accès à la défense au dossier
de l'accusation au contraire même je
pense simplement que il y a un certain
nombre nombre d'éléments qui peuvent de
par la loi prévoir et c'est d'ailleurs
le cas l'anonymat d'un certain nombre
d'informateurs mais pas des informations
euh quant un un l'uttilage d'un certain
nombre d'outils disons qui relève plutôt
du monde du renseignement dans le cadre
de procédure judiciaire avec le pseudo
informateur X27 c'est déjà largement le
cas et ça ne donne pas beaucoup accès à
la défense euh dans la manière dont elle
peut gérer ce type d'affaire enfin
le nombre d'erreurs procédurales qui
amène à la libération de trafiquants ou
de criminels du fait de l'encombrement
massif de nos juridictions de faiblebles
moyens notamment des greffes du fait que
les magistrats n'arrivent plus à s'en
sortir tellement ils ont dossier à
traiter est un problème bien plus
important que le fait de cacher des
éléments à la défense la défense est
largement pourvue en faute de procédure
sans qu'on ait besoin en plus de lui
cacher le cont des dossiers voilà qui
est clair
[Musique]
etè Mariel Carlotti et Catherine con
nous ont rejoint Marl Carlot merci je
suis désolé pour Marseille oui mais on
est habitué habitué d'autant que je vais
revenir un peu sur
Marseille finalement c'est pas c'est pas
démoralisant ce que vous dites parce que
vous avez dit quand même qu'en 70 avec
un coup de fil de Nixon on a pu arrêter
toutes les gars qui avait fait la
frenche avec les labos de qualité qui
était à Marseille grand de très grande
qualité qui était à Marseille donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a s'il y a une volonté
politique avec une loi qui donne
certainement pas satisfaction mais qui
est sortie d'un coup de téléphone et
d'une volonté politique et c'est bien ça
qui nous importe à nous dans ce dans
cette commission d'enquête c'est de de
porter derrière une volonté politique
pour attaquer pour attaquer ce sujet
alors il y a l' haut du spectre moi qui
m'importe beaucoup mais c'est même pas
là-dessus que je vais vous poser une
question c'est sur la question du
traitement médical et des addictions je
sais que vous êtes pas médecin mais vous
avez quand même fait référence à quelque
chose que j'avais lu quand j'étais très
jeune d' olivenstein qui a écrit il n'y
a pas de drogué heureux et il y avait
des expériences qui étaient en cours
notamment à Marseille par le docteur
Prat qui qui menait ces expérien je sais
pas si on s'en souvient bien moi je m'en
souviens pas trop peut-être que vous les
avez en tête mais est-ce que ces
expériences qui étaient quand même assez
libertaires malgré tout sur certains
plans parce que il disait qu'il y avait
pas d'accro à la cocaïne et cetera la
drogue était pas la même à l'époque elle
ne est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
s'inspirer des propositions qui ont lieu
qui étaient à titre expérimentaux qui
n'ont jamais été vraiment soutenu ça
c'est ma première question même si vous
êtes pas médecin donnez-moi une piste
là-dessus et l'autre question c'est
concernant les les petits dealers de
quartier vous disiez tout à l'heure une
courte peine pour les mineurs c'est
c'est très efficace et moi courte peine
très rapide d'accord parce que c'est pas
la courte peine c'est la cassure la
cassure pardonaccord préciser parce que
moi je vois tellement des des jeunes qui
sont peut-être pas des mineurs
d'ailleurs qui ont un bracelet qui
remonent le surv pour qu'on voie le
bracelet ça leur donne au contraire donc
j'ai besoin de précision sur ces deux po
oui alors pardon si je réponds au f à
mesure d'abord oui il y a eu beaucoup
d'expérience aucun bilan
aucun autant le rapport
perfite juste avant 1981 avait fait en
20 volumes le plus beau et le plus
impressionnant bilan de l'état de la CR
ité de la délinquence de des problèmes
urbains de un diagnostic absolument
remarquable qui n'a provoqué ni
pronostic ni thérapeutique bon mais au
moins C
fait après 81 on a eu un certain nombre
de propositions qui ont été réalisées
sur certains un nombre important de
secteurs mais qui ont amené une
problématique complète de ne pas se
montrer trop
complaisant parce que il y avait une un
en incompétence et
en
philobanditisme qui s'est arrêtait après
l'affaire action directe les attentats
ont créé les conditions d'un retour à
l'ordre au majuscule et on est revenu à
un projet à peu près intelligent qui
était des citoyens libres dans des
villes sûres coloc dit de ville peinte
issu anciennement du rapport bonne
maison alors c'est à peu près tous les
15 ans la gauche a une une épiphanie
elle elle découvre parce qu'elle est aux
affaires de la plupart des collectivités
territoriales que cette question doit
être traitée et d'ailleurs c'est assez
intéressant parce que c'est une gauche
Janus alors je dis ça avec facilité
parce que j'en ai connu beaucoup j'étais
collaborateur de Michel Rocard pendant
très longtemps ils étaient extrêmement
rationnels et normaux entre au sens de
la normalité de la prise en compte du
problème au niveau local et arrivé à
Paris une transformation avait lieu et
on avait des négationnistes culturels
c'estd en fait le problème n'existait
pas c'était une invention de la droite
alors ça évidemment ça pose un problème
c'est que ça construit l'opposition sur
le thème un voilà la France c'est le
pays de négation minoration éjection 1
c'est pas vrai deux c'est pas grave et
tris c'est pas de ma faute ce qui fait
que le citoyen lambda pour qu' c'est
vrai c'est grave et il fallait bien
trouver quelqu'un qui s'en occupe décide
de s'adresser aux extrêmes parce qu'au
moins les extrêmes lui donnent une
réponse certes elle n'est pas bonne mais
il y en a une et puis surtout elle
commence pas par dire que c'est pas vrai
ce qui est quand même un vrai problème
quand vous le quand vous le subissez
tous les jours c'est un sentiment alors
qu'en fait nous vivons un climat c'est
pas la même chose sentiment c'est un
truc évaporé le climat c'est ce qu'on
rendc compre tous les jour que ça soit
plus ou moins grave c'est un peu pr
comme les gens qui n'aiment pas
l'obscurité vous avez le droit de vous
moquer d'eux mais vous pouvez pas penser
que ça n'existe pas la reconnaissance du
réel est un élément majeur donc dans mon
métier c'est une science clinique on
fait un diagnostic et le diagnostic doit
être partagé on le fait assez peu
ensuite on établit un pronostic il doit
être discutéah évidemment si on a pas de
diagnostique c'est complexe ensuite on a
un droit à une débat thérapeutique qui
peut être extrêmement disputé et on
s'engueule nous avons le pays des
meilleurs thérapeutes du monde sans
diagnostic ça donc marche pas terrible
terrible et c'est valable pas seulement
pour les questions criminelles ou le
trafic de stup donc le vraie question
qui existe c'est quel bilan on a de
toutes ces expériences à marmottant et
ailleurs et alors je peux vous en
citer elles sont anciennes il y en a qui
survivent ici et là mais pas de bilan
pas de proposition le seul qui a tenté
vraiment un travail de fond c'est la
mission de l'Assemblée nationale l'année
dernière dernière sur la
question de la dépénalisation enfin je
vais le faire brutalement voilà on a
chez nous une revue à l'intérie de notre
centre de recherche auoknam qui
s'appelle politique des drogues où
cohabite alors à peu près tous les
points de vue les répressifs comme moi
c'està-dire le problème n'est pas la
libéralisation mais la désaddiction la
désaddiction c'est c'est une mesure
visant à s'en sortir c'est pas une
mesure en disant allez-y youi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire mais qui dit c'est
pas un sujet pénal c'est un sujet
médical mais l'injonction fait partie
des Mo médicaux on peut vous donner des
injonctions à des tas de choses vous
vaccinez par exemple pour prendre un
exemple pas si lointain donc
l'injonction comme un élément de
politique médicale élément structurant
d'une politique de réponse au fléau de
la consommation et par ailleurs de
réponse au réseau et au trafic dans cet
ordre là pas l'inverse voilà donc ça
c'est une réponse à ça et on pourrait
faire un bilan d'ailleurs Sénat a tous
les moyens de faire un bilan des
expériences menées pour pour les
politiques de
désaddiction avec tout ce qui a été
utile et tout ce qui était totalement
farfelu parce qu'il y a eu des choses
très farfelu vous avez raison hein mais
c'était valable aussi pour toute une
série de mesures des années 70 mais
justement le bilan c'est fait pour faire
le tri entre ce qui était utile ce qui
aurait pu marcher ce qui aurait pu être
généralisé ce qui aurait pu être modulé
ce qui aurait pu être proposé et puis ce
qui n'avait aucun sens et qui s'est
terminé comme voilà c'est comme les
politiques de santé publique en matière
de psychiatrie j'ai l'idée de fermer les
centes fermé pour dire qu'on all les
tout réglé en milieu ouvert a amené le
désastre de la psychiatrie nationale les
psychiatres ayant eux-même participer à
leur propre auto extinction mais ils en
sont revenus donc on peut avancer en
faisant le bilan qui est neutre de ce
qui a été fait deuxièmement il y a une
série de propositions et de dispositifs
qui peuvent parfaitement fonctionner sur
la base de ce qui a été bien fait euh et
qui avait donné des résultats et à
marmottant et ailleurs puisque il y a eu
des bilans régionaux locaux de
subvention publiques euh il y a quelques
années mon collègue Sébastien Rocher a
été financé par une mutuelle pour
faire des enquêtes d'auto-incrimination
où les auteurs d'actes de délincant
expliquaient pourquoi ils le faisaient
bah c'est pas inintéressant de demander
aux gens pourquoi il décident de devenir
des délinquants ou des criminels
notamment des gens qui étaient dans le
trafic de stup enfin pour ce qui est
dans la réponse pénale alors elle n'est
pas liée au trafiquant de stupéfiant en
tant que tel elle dit simplement que
dans mon dispositif de 60 sur 100 primo
30 secondo et 5 tout hyper productif le
moment où on décide de casser le rythme
du la carrière criminelle du glissement
vieillesse technicité criminelle de la
progression criminelle c'est le moment
où on la casse le plus vite possible le
plus rapidement possible et de la
manière la plus rapide possible et c'est
pas avec un bracelet c'est c'est pas
avec un isolement un moment où justement
on a plus de téléphone bref un moment où
tout d'un coup on est face à soi-même et
a un accompagnement qui
dit va falloir s'arrêter tout de suite
parce que voilà et ça ne va marcher que
dans 70 % des cas pas 100 % et ensuite
ça remarchera dans 30 % plus ou moins
vite et à la fin il restera les 5 % sur
lequel on peut mobiliser massivement les
forces de répression pénal pour isoler
50 % de l'activité criminelle pour 5 %
des auteurs vous imaginez la
reconcentration de moyens sur le noyau
d' dur alors entendons-nous bien les 5 %
c'est une représentation c'est pas les
mêmes 5 % quels que soi les types
d'activités criminell je précise pour
tous mes collègues qui vont regarder ça
et qui vont dire oui mais tu n'as pas
précisé que avec la note méthodologique
de 27 pages qui accompagne tout
statistiques qui se respecte donc je le
fais pour dire que oui je sais mais pour
vous donner cette image la
reconcentration des moyens sur le noyau
dur de l'activité criminelle de
l'activité d'incante de l'activité
stupéfiante elle a des effets
elle a des effets simplement on ne
laisse pas perdurer l'emmerdement
quotidien des deux dealers qui sont en
bas de chez vous parce qu'on est en
train de remonter la filière et que
pendant ce temps-là on s'occupe pas des
deux qui sont là on s'occupe des deux
qui sont là mais d'une manière plus
intelligente que d'habitude on sature le
terrain parce que ça c'est important et
de revenir à une police de présence
visibilité proximité qu'on a oublié al
c'est pas la police de proximité je
précise bien ça n'a rien à voir police
proximité ça marche dans les états
fédéraux où le maire est le patron de sa
police et décide de ce qu'il fait là où
il a envie de le faire c'est une police
qui sature le terrain c'est pas une
police d'intervention qui vient de temps
en temps mais on peut trouver des moyens
et les adapter y compris en terme de
répression et de sanction rapide
efficace limité dans le temps mais qui
ne fait pas durer
117 interpellations
90 présentations au juges et au dernier
moment nul ne sait pourquoi TR enferm
parce que ça n'est c'est
incompréhensible pour tout le monde le
système les victimes et les auteurs
c'est c'est donc il y a un souci dans
l'application du dispositif le fait de
vouloir systématiquement trouver des
alternatives à tout ne règle rien s'il y
a pas un contenu à l'alternative
aujourd'hui l'alternative c'est
classement sans suite injonction faut
pas le refaire enfin des choses qui
n'ont pas d'ffet dans la réalité en tout
cas pour une partie importante des
acteurs qui sont ceux qui sont les plus
perturbateurs et les plus hors du
système pénal et surtout du respect de
de de règles de vie ensemble que tout le
monde aime le vivre ensemble
moi aussi une une question de Catherine
Conconne je poserai la mi merci merci
président merci al ber pour ses
éclairages Carine concon sénatrice de
Martinique sujet préant la drogue ça
passe par la création de nouvelles
filières de formation de nouveaux
métiers oui parce que ces
personnes que vous destinez à être prise
en charge autrement avec une alternative
avec du contenu qui va faire ça quel
sont ces métiers qu'il faudra désormais
créer amplifier
performer pour que on puisse s'occuper
de ce petit monde parce que c'est pas un
policier qui va le faire c'est pas un
juge ce sera à bon des travails il y a
une telle nébuleuse dans le milieu de la
médiation et cetera donc qui et comment
alors vous savez quand je viens ici au
Parlement je suis toujours entre demand
si je suis une espèce en voie
d'apparition ou disparition parce que en
France sur l'ensemble du territoire
national d'homme et Thomme compris il y
a un professeur de criminologie pas deux
hein
un pourquoi parce que la criminologie
est considérée comme un outil patate
chaude les sociolâtres je parle pas des
sociologue pour qui j'ai le plus grand
respect mais c'est un culte la
sociolatrie considère qu'en fait il y a
pas de mal la société est mauvaise et
les individus sont bons c'est une sorte
de rousoïme étrange euh voilà les
pénalistes pensent que seul le droit va
répondre à cette question et en fait
chacun fonctionne en tuyau d'or sans
jamais se parler ni se rencontrer ni se
concerter et au nom de la sacrinte
indépendance médicale pénal judiciaire
et cetera et puis sur le terrain vous
découvrez subitement que des tas de gens
s'occupent du sujet à marmotan des
acteurs de terrain des associations des
gardiens de prison des magistrats des
avocats des défenseurs des droit mais
ils le font voilà à la petite semaine
dans leur coin et cetera et puis quand
vous leur offrait un un terrain euh de
d'apprentissage et surtout de partage de
retour d'expérience de reconnaissance
voilà moi j'ai 330 étudiants cette année
j'en ai pas deux je n'ai pas qu'un un
doctorat résiduel pour
répressif extrémiste donc pourquoi parce
qu'il y a une extraordinaire demande et
mes étudiants bah ils sont très sociaux
très médicaux très penaux très policiers
très magistrats très avocats très
défenseurs des très journalistes parce
qu' ils ont besoin d'apprendre et de
partager et de comprendre et donc les
espaces existent
paradoxalement les populations
concernées existent parce que ça sera
beaucoup plus de formation permanente
d'accompagnement supplémentaire à ce
qu'ils savent déjà faire ce qu'il
ressentent sur le terrain que de
formation initiale mais le jour où on
créera de la formation initiale vous
aurez des centaines de candidat après il
faudra créer des supports d'emploi et là
vous allez entrer dans un débat
budgétaire quoi qu'il en coûte quoi
qu'il en coûte plus ça dépend des jours
faut voir enfin vous connaissez cette
histoire aussi bien que moi mais dans la
réalité la quasittalité des besoins
pardon des moyens existent invisible non
coordonnés non concertés non reconnus
non respecté aussi tout le monde se fout
de ce qu'ils font éventuellement fait un
petit chèque de subvention si vous créez
une par exemple la France n'a pas de
conférence nationale de
criminologie on s'est jamais rencontré
pour parler des des affaires criminelles
jamais il m'arrive d'aller faire cours
dans un endroit formidable qui est qui
au fleur il y a une rencontre où des
policiers des gendarmes et des
magistrats se parle de politique pénale
comme il y a pas de journaliste personne
ne
s'engueule les flics ne sont pas
fascistes les magistrats ne sont pas
laxistes et on discute et certains de
mes collègues sont invités à venir faire
des conférences qui permettent le débat
sur les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce ou pas la politique pénale
en liberté c'est un truc formidable
c'est une annexe de l'École Nationale
magistrature donc je n'en dis pas
toujours du bien mais je profite de ce
moment pour dire qu'il y a des endroits
c'est l'école nationale supérieur de
police fait la même chose on a les mêmes
activités assez régulièrement pour la
manière dont on forme les analystes du
renseignement parce que dans le
renseignement il y a aussi le
renseignement criminel c'est pas
seulement l'espionnage international et
donc on fait passer des idées et en fait
il y a d'extraordinaires compétences de
terrain elles sont partout on les
rencontre partout je suis allé l'autre
jour à une conférence des euh personnel
d'assistance psychologique des
départements qui avit connu un drame
parce que une d'entre elles s'était fait
assassiner par quelqu'un qui était
disons plus perturbé que d'autres mais
il y avait des des des ils étaient
plusieurs dizaines on a eu un un débat
d'une richesse d'une qualité avec des
interrogations la diversité des
expériences mais qui ne sont reconnues
par personne en tout cas seulement dans
le petit circuit professionnel du petit
morceau du tuyau où on discute en fait
la la ressource elle est là elle demande
qu'à émerger comme
toujours le lendemain de mon élection
comme professeur de criminologie j'ai
découvert que j'avais 40
collègues clandestin sans papier de la
criminau ce que j'appelle qui exerçait
sous des titres et des noms divers dans
des tas d'université et qui enfin
maintenant qu'ils avaient un point de
référence sont tous arrivés pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour aider le
conser atoire à se développer moi je
pensais être tout seul en fait on était
40 mais je suis le seul émergé on va
dire donc maintenant il y a un institut
de criminologie à Lille qui assume
totalement sa vision il y a de la
victimologie à peau qui assume
totalement son point de vue il y a de la
médecine légale de très bonne qualité
psy psy PSI anant et et Ren il y en a à
Poitier on commence à voir apparaître
des pôles non centralisé puisque on
n'arrive pas à avoir de reconnaissance
des carrières parce que c'est ça qui
pose problème mes collègues ils en font
de la criminaux sans le dire en
attendant que sans que personne ne les
voit des fois que ça leur nuise en terme
de carrière moi j'ai atteint le plus
haut niveau doncant avant la retraite
bientôt sauf si vous la repoussez
euh voilà mais la reconnaissance du
niveau c'est il suffit de faire une
conférence nationale ouverte ouverte pas
consensuelle ouverte sans journaliste
parce que c'est l'élément perturbateur
désolé c'est pas que je ne veux pas que
les médias soient là c'est que les
médias doivent être là après pas pendant
où chacun va pouvoir enfin se parler de
savoir comment on règle une partie des
questions qu'on viendir et vous allez
voir à quel point la compétence du
terrain est exceptionnellement
développée en France et à quel point la
structure centralisée nationale
parisienne bureaucratique de l'État est
totalement c'est les c'est les trois
singes en un seul sourde aveugle
muette vous décrivez un paysage où on a
privilégié de manière confuse maladroite
désordonné une répression tous àimute au
détriment du soin dans dans la réalité
de la consommation des des stupéfiants
est-ce qu'il y a une place à part pour
quelque chose qui échappe aux soins qui
serait de l'ordre du récréatif que je
entre guillemets et puis deuxè question
dans l'approche que nous avons
actuellement répressive vous vous dites
on tape de la même manière
indistinctement sur le consommateur le
consommateur de dealer et le trafiquant
euh y y a-t-il une une une solution une
voie euh par la modification de
l'échelle des
Pen alors d'abord le problème du
récréatif c'est qu'il peut être addictif
moi c'est le récréatif m'iffère c'est
l'addiction qui me pose problème alors
quand c'est un médicament extrêmement
addictif mais qui permet de résoudre la
question de la douleur ça ne me dérange
pas qu'il soit addictif parce qu'il est
traité d'une manière médicale sous
contrôle médical et pour régler un
problème médical ce qui explique
d'ailleurs les référendum aux États-Unis
où tous était extraordinairement
favorable à la
libéralisation la dépénalisation la
décriminalisation la tout ce que vous
voulez de tout ce qui était justement
lié à des processus médicamenteux liés
notamment au cancer et à des maladies
extrêmement douloureuses et qui sont
considéré comme des médicaments comme
toute une série d'opiacés qui sont
devenus des médicaments et qu'on a dont
on a a oublié qu'ils étaient des
médicaments comme des tas de médicaments
détournés de leur usage genre des
fintanil AL je prends pas le Médiator
qui est pas addictif mais qui est
dangereux mais toute une série de
médicaments qui enfin de médicaments
détournés d'usage qui permettent par des
mélanges de devenir des produits
dangereux et addictifs donc moi le
récréatif pas le récréatif c'est pas le
sujet c'est l'addiction qui me pose
problème et de ce point de vue-là
l'addiction doit être traitée d'un point
de vue médical même si dans la tête des
gens rcréative comme non je ne je suis
pas alcoolique mais j'en suis à mon 4e
apéro sa c'est c'est une addiction c'est
tout j'ai rien contre l'apéritif mais il
y a des moments où faut intégrer le
niveau d'alcolimisation et du risque que
ça représente alors par exemple che dans
le Colorado territoire que je connais
bien aux États-Unis ou c'est un
référendum populaire qui a décidé ça
l'augmentation du nombre d'accidents de
personnes sous influence de cannabis ou
de produits cannabinoïdes et cetera ou
de champignons allucinogène a augmenté
de manière massive alors ils sont
dangereux pour les autres parceils sont
des accidents de voiture mais c'est
valable aussi pour l'alcool et
d'ailleurs la plupart d'entre eux sont
aussi alcoolisés donc pour moi c'est un
problème d'addiction vous voyez c'est
pas un problème de pénalisation même
s'il faut les punir hein il y a pas
surtout s blesse ou tue quelqu'un
d'autre mais la question elle est
différente donc addictif enfin récréatif
par récréatif je le prends pas en
considération je je j'entends bien la
différence que vous faites mais pour moi
ça change pas ça change pas quant à
échelle des peines euh alors si les
peines étaient effectives et donc si on
appliquait la loi de 1970 que plus
personne ne fait parce qu'elle est
inapplicable oui bien sûr il faudrait
mais déjà faudrait commencer par changer
le texte pour indiquer ce qu'est la
réalité d'un processus qui doit
commencer par le médical et pas le pénal
donc c'est pas l'échelle des peine qui
est l'élément majeur parce que moi je
suis pour que un grand trfrican
responsable de plusieurs centaines de
morts parce qu'il a surdosé un produit
s'il peut prendre 30 ans et sans
autorisation de sortie je n'y vois pas
d'uncinant je précise que je suis
abolitionniste donc je n'ai pas de
d'option peine de mort mais juste en
dessous j'ai aucun problème avec la
répression massive des trafiquants des
recelleurs des blanchisseurs et de tous
ceux qui sachant ce qu'ils vendent
sachant ce qu'ils vendent prennent la
responsabilité de la mortalité de ceux
qui le consomment c'est aucun problème
mais c'est pas ça la question la
question c'est pas l'échelle des peines
c'est une question secondaire enfin
c'est pas ça la question initiale pour
être plus précis c'est une question
secondaire la question initiale c'est
quel est l' ordre de priorité l'ordre de
priorité c'est de s'occuper des malades
ensuite c'est de s'occuper des entre
deux les dealur consommateurs et enfin
c'est de réprimer je dire sauvagement
avec la plus grande force de la loi
comme disent les Américains les
trafiquants et ce qui va
avec merci mariearlette scarlottis oui
excusez-moi de
réinvenir justement je voudrais parler
de justement de cela des gros
trafiquants et du haut du spectre les
réseaux criminels on le sait il font feu
de tout bois pour faire de l'argent ils
font de l'argent sur tout ce qui bouge
en quelque sorte c'est le principe ouais
c'est ça d'après vous est-ce quels sont
les liens entre les trafics de drogue et
aussi les autres formes de trafic est-ce
qu'il y a des porosités entre le trafic
d'armes ou les trafic d'êtes humains par
exemple et est-ce que c'est un
traitement spécifique sur pour suivre
les réseaux sur le trafic de drogue par
rapport aux autres formes de trafic il y
a un gros travail qui est fait sur la
question du terrorisme beaucoup moins
sur les trafiquants de drogue alors en
fait dans les années so 6
70 le système criminel et notamment le
système mafieux qui est beaucoup moins
développé hein parce que nous en France
tout est mafieux mais en fait c'est pas
vrai hein les mafias il y en a
relativement peu elles sont très
puissantes mais en France on a du crime
organisé qui avait tenté d'avoir des
relations avec la mafia mais qui en a
relativement peu dans la réalité le
système était très sectorisé chacun
avait sa petite spécialité et puis
euh après l'apparition de laandrangetta
et de la Camora ça a tout changé il y a
eu une modernisation massive et donc
tout le monde fait tout il n'y a plus de
spécialité plus par exemple vous prenez
les centres de
prostitution le long de la frontière
espagnole ce sont des centres de
prostitution et de distribution de stup
désormais on est
multiervice les réseaux de blanchiment
d'argent à 90 % servent à la frautete
fiscale ce qu'on appelle l'optimisation
fiscale dès lors que vous avez un truc
offshore quelque part il est illégal
dangereux et devrait être interdit point
ça ne sert qu'à la fraude sur ces tuyaux
se
branche plein d'autres choses le
blanchiment la rétrocommission l'argent
du terrorisme c'est très petit
évidemment l'argent des
stupes l'argent des stupes c'est estimé
à vue de nez tout compris trafic est
stup 5 % du PIB mondial et 20 à 25 % des
dépôts et à peu près 70 % 50 à 70
% des offshor cumulativement pas en
rythme anuel parce que c'est assez
difficile d'en faire quelque chose
puisque la lutte antiblanchimement
fonctionne quand même plus ou moins bien
plus ou moins bien parce que les cryptos
ont créé un nouvel espace de liberté au
blanch
mais aujourd'hui tout le monde fait tout
en fait pour des raisons que vous avez
parfaitement indiqué c'est le gain et
donc si je peux faire ça et en même
temps faire autre chose et rapporter
plus à la fin pourquoi pas et nous avons
d'aujourd'hui une intégration en fait le
crime et notamment le trafic de stup
c'est le modèle le plus abouti de
l'économie de marché intégration
verticale intégration horizontale
investissement dans la recherche et
développement développement des zones de
chalandise peti incentive pour le petit
personnel seule la gestion de la
concurrence est plus définitive que dans
le commerce
traditionnel très bien dans les
questions que nous avons posé vous
pardon non vous dans les questions vous
a posé on vous a parlé de l'ubérisation
du trafic
et vous avez fait quelques propositions
notamment l'identification en l'identité
numérique vous pouvez détailler un petit
peu tout ça bah nous avons grâce à
François premier à qui je tiens à rendre
hommage depuis 1539 un état civil qui
nous permet d'avoir une identité je
crois que vous appelez Étienne blanc et
si je regarde votre numéro national
d'identité Vous êtes un quelque chose
quelque chose quelque je ne donnerai pas
l'ann voilà et puis voilà et c'est votre
numéro c'est votre identité on sait que
vous êtes né on sait où vous êtes né le
mois où vous êtes né et puis par la
suite de votre vie ce numéro va
permettre de savoir toute une série de
choses de votre vie sociale et au moment
d'une éventuelle disparition la plus
lointaine possible on pourra même savoir
comment et dans quelles conditions vous
vous êtes disparu parce que le
l'identifiant du l'hôpital ou du médecin
légiste ou bref va permettre de savoir
ces éléments là et donc ça nous donne
une idée qui permet d'avoir une analyse
démographique de la vie des individus et
du fait qu'on est tant de millions
d'habitants dans telles conditions avec
un âge moyen qui une natalité qui baisse
et cetera et cetera et quand on a ouvert
les espace numérique pour des raisons
étranges on a décidé qu'on a'urait pas
d'identité numérique parce que c'était
une atteinte à nos libertés c'est un peu
le concept de on va créer des autoroutes
mais pas de code de la route
ou le pH West sans
shérif or le seul moyen d'avoir une
garantie de compréhension de l'ensemble
de l'activité numérique notamment
illégale de la rageosphère des trolls
des des
des des agresseurs
des
hurleurs des menaceurs des dingues qui
s'expriment sur Internet comme si on
était en pleine liberté et qu'il n'y
avait aucun risque c'est de garantir non
pas qu'il n''est pas de pseudo mais que
leur identité numérique garantisse le
fait qu'on sache que pour avoir accès à
Internet et ben leur première adresse
c'est
etienne.blancfance.gou.fr et que tout le
reste ne puisse découler que de cette
adresse
là quel que soit les 27 pseudos vous
allez décider d'utiliser du genre Gon de
la Croix Rousse bon parce que ça va
permettre de résoudre une partie
importante de l'excès de violence et de
trollisation et de rageosphère sur un
espace que nous n'avons pas voulu
réguler et que nous ne savons pas
toujours réguler ceci est donc aussi
valable pour les services offerts sur
Internet dans le cadre de l'ubérisation
ou en commandant sa pizza on peut aussi
se faire livrer sa dosette ou C dozet
parce que tout ça passe par des messages
qui eux-mêm passent sur des réseaux qui
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce que tout
le monde raconte sont beaucoup moins
sécurisés qu'on l'imagine parce que dès
lors que notamment les services de
police gendarmerie décident de s'y
mettre vraiment bah on sent bien que
voilà hein on n'est pas exactement dans
ce qu'on croit et que les les
dispositifs peuvent être contournés ou
cassés et fort heureusement d'ailleurs
pour l'instant d'ailleurs le jour où on
passera au quantique on est à peu PRS
sûr que plus aucun système de
cryptographie ne pourra résister à quoi
que ce soit ce qui est à la fois une
interrogation une inquiétude et une
satisfaction ça dépend de quel point de
vue on se passe mais en contrepartie on
a le plus grand mal à identifier
l'auteur on on casse les messages mais
on a encore plus de mal à identifier les
auteurs parce que ils utilisent des
identités numériques qui ne sont pas
obligatoires al le fait d'avoir une
identité numérique est un élément qui
peut
parfaitement faciliter ça n'empêchera
pas tout mais ça va réduire massive
ement
l'ampleur du développement notamment des
réseaux de contournement de distribution
donc je rappelle que par ailleurs il
n'empêche pas les points de Deal il se
rajoute au point de Deal et au lieu de
résoudre une partie du problème de la
nuisance de proximité vous avez nuisance
de proximité plus le livreur à la maison
ce qui est pas
terrible vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pardon j'ai coupé vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est en tapant au portefeuille
qu'on est efficace qu'est-ce qui fait
défaut aujourd'hui euh au code pénal au
code de procédure pénale sur la
poursuite contre le blanchiment
qu'est-ce qui fait défaut dans
l'organisation de nos services le mixte
judiciaire
euh services douigners services fiscaux
comment voyez les choses bon il a fallu
les attentats de 2015 et 2016 pour enfin
avoir une coopération antiterroriste
efficace entre services qui ne se
coopéraent pas beaucoup pour des raisons
à la fois légitimes à la protection de
des sources et pour moins légitime c'est
à moi c'est pas à toi pour des problèmes
de judiciarisation aussi car partie du
renseignement disponible n'arrive par
des voies impénétrabl celle du du
Seigneur sans doute euh et donc il y a
un même enjeu pour la coopération stup
que pour la
coopération euh terro mais à condition
de s'occuper des choses essentielles de
ne pas noyer l'activité antistupéfiant
dans le le le le le consommateur du coin
donc il faut réorienter en donnant plus
de moyens l'oface est une bonne idée
quand tuas un réemballage de l'idée
précédente qui elle-même est un
réemballage des Gires qui elle-même
voilà on a on n pas manqué d'idée on est
meilleur dans les idées que dans
l'application c'est le drame du pays et
c'est valable pour la police ou la
gendarmerie ou ce que vous voulez que
que pour la plupart des service public
mais en tout cas on ne manque pas des
moyens le fait d'avoir une incitation
forte et un outil puissant euh qui
permet de donner des résultats y compris
sur les cryptos moi je regarde avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les résultats je
travaille beaucoup avec les nopido aux
États-Unis mais aussi avec les les
services fédéraux alors moi c'est plutôt
l'antiterrorisme mais du coup on parle
un peu de tout quand on est en réunion
je vois les nouveaux outils de suivi des
cryptoonnaaies c'est extrêmement
efficace et ça démontre que en fait
quand on veut on peut identifier qui a
pris quoi et où ça va quitte même
d'ailleurs à le faire disparaître de
temps en temps aux grandes dâes des
opérateurs criminels et après tout je
veux dire une arrivée
soudaine euh d'une recette extra
budgétaire dans notre pays ne ferit de
mal à personne notamment pour financer
des gens pour s'occuper des problèmes
médicaux une question complémentaire au
fil de nos auditions on nous a parlé des
techniques les plus récentes euh les
cryptos on nous a aussi parlé de de
techniques beaucoup plus anciennes et
rudimentaires type Awala ah oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a des des des façons de
s'en prémunir parce que ça a l'air
d'être plus compliqué à gérer pour la
puissance publique bah d'abord il faut
gérer des problèmes auquels nous avons
nous-même donné la main c'est-à-dire les
centres de transfert d'argent non
contrôlé dont même il fut un temps la
poste était un
opérateur bienveillant de la même
manière que on pouvait transformer de
l'argent liquide en virement pour payer
ses loyers puisque tout ce qui tombe du
camion ne finit pas uniquement dans des
loisirs hein il y a une dimension
sociale aux petites mains du frafic qu'
faut pas sous-estimer ça permet aussi de
payer le permis de conduire ça permet de
payer les loyers ça permet de payer des
tas de trucs beaucoup plus créatifs ou
en tout cas auquels on ne pense pas et
où nous avions toute une série
d'opérateurs qui pour des raisons
d'activité euh naturelle de business
considérrait qu'il fallait pas regarder
nù venait l'argent et où il allait et
donc par exemple dans le secteur des des
HLM vous aviez trois éléments
indicateurs d'une crise rotation
vacances
impayé/ash paiement en liquide qui
étaient des éléments qui permettaient
quand le taux de rotation s'accélérait
que le taux de vacances grandissait que
le taux d'impayé croissait vous aviez
une crise dans votre secteur HLM et par
ailleurs quand le pourcentage de
paiement en liquide ou sous mandat
devenait trop important c'est donc les
modes de règlement euh des loyers
changaient de nature ce sont des
indicateurs fiables stables comme les
indicateurs médicaux des urgences qui
sont plus fiables et plus stables que le
nombre de coups et blessures volontaires
enregistré par les services de police ou
de
gendarmerie parce que tous ne le sont
pas tous ne sont pas déclarés mais tout
le monde va aux urgences donc il faut
toujours se doter de plusieurs outils
dont certains ne sont purement pas
sécuritaires pour avoir une vision plus
plus précise de la réalité comme nous
avions fait des enquêtes de victimation
pour avoir une vision plus précise de la
réalité alors que les dépôts de de
plaines ne suffit suffisait pas ou les
mains courantes ne suffisaient pas à
avoir une une un état de ce que les gens
subissaient vous découvrez par exemple
que on est mieux informé sur les bris de
véhicules et la manière dont votre
rétroviseur a été cassé parce que vous
avez besoin de déclarer aux assurances
que sur les violences intrafamilial hein
67 % dans l'un 9 % dans l'autre et donc
quand vous avez que 9 % de déclaration
de violence intrafamiliale régulière
récurrente où les gens vivent ensemble
c'est un peu plus important qu'un
rétroviseur sauf qu'on s'est jamais
occupé de l'un et on s'est beaucoup
occupé enfin on CIT c'est un processus
lent Mitou est arrivé la civise est
arrivé sur les questions d'inceste et
cetera mais on se rend compte du retard
nous sommes en 2023 2024 pas 1923 1924
hélas donc c'est c'est un sujet qui est
simplement mécanique je dirais mais tous
les processus en question sont connus
nous les avons aidés facilité pour des
raisons de business nous pouvons
parfaitement y remédier ceci dit les
banquiers lombardes ça date de Philippe
Lebel
et ils ont été très utiles à Lyon oui et
vous avez parlé des divergences
européennes vous entendiez quoi par ces
diverg Belgique Pays-Bas versus les
autres mais sur
quel
libéralisation libéralisation de la
consommation et puis de tout et sur la
poursuite bah il y a pas de poursuite de
facto qui a pris le contrôle qui prend
le contrôle des coffee shop en au P
la
mafia parce que le problème n'est plus
de faire de la prohibition c'est de
prendre le contrôle du réseau de
distribution les organisations
criminelles savent toujours où trouver
l'argent qu'il leur faut en Californie
le grand problème qui est aujourd'hui
vécu c'est que les pharmacies du
cannabis ça s'appelle comme ça sont
aujourd'hui contrôlé par les
criminels tous les petits gérants ont
été éjectés ils le contrôle a été voilà
c'est donc il y a toujours un moment où
le dispositif pêche par le
réinvestissement criminel euh pour
prendre le contrôle de quelque chose sur
euh et donc les Pays-Bas d'un côté mais
nos amis belges sont en grande
difficulté nos amis espagnols les
portugais ne savent plus à quel sain
vousouer par rapport à leur politique de
décriminalisation dont ils sentent à la
fois les difficultés et les excès euh
c'està que toujours un moment où tu vis
l'effet pervers de l'excès qui a eu lieu
et donc tout tout le monde se rend bien
compte que quand on on n'anticipe pas la
problématique et la cohérence d'un choix
et ben on a un sujet il y a un État
américain qui a tout décriminalisé en
stupéfiant tout qui vit aujourd'hui une
crise médicale sanitaire majeure parce
que le monde entier vient chez eux parce
que tout est autorisé donc tous les
excès étant autorisés tous les effets
excessifs se retrouvent là-bas et donc
vous avez un sujet qui est que comme
c'est pas un état fermé par c'est des
états des États-Unis ils sont en train
de se poser le problème du surcût de
gestion des overdose surdose criminalité
et cetera d à l'importation massive de
consommateurs de produits qui ne sont
même pas autorisés dans les 37 autres
États qui ont plus ou moins
décricriminalisé dépénalisé
contraventionnalisé ou libéraliser la
production de divers types de
stupéfiants et je parle pas seulement
des des affaires euh de de gestion de
stupéfiants pour des raisons médicales
où là il y a un vrai enjeu
reste j'entends bien ce que vous dites
sur la libéralisation de la consommation
et je voulais parler sur la poursuite
des réseaux sur le poursuite contre le
blanchiment est-ce que mais on poursuit
plus rien mais qu'est-ce qu'on veut
qu'est-ce qu'on peut poursuivre on
poursuit encore les trafiquants en
Belgique et au Pays Bas en Belgique oui
au Pays-Bas quasiment pas qu'est-ce
qu'on poursuit c'est quoi
l'incrimination quand quand la drogue
arrive sur un port on saisit et on
poursuit ah on saisit et on poursuit
mais quand elle arrive sur le port et
quand on la saisi sur le port oui le
problème c'est que comme la consommation
est autorisée après la consommation
c'est le Réau bah oui mais si la
consommation est autorisée il faut bien
qu'il y a un réseau de distribution les
coffee shop sont autorisés donc on peut
importer légalement et les réseaux de
distribution non autorisés je pense
notamment sur la cocaïne est-ce que
selon vous l'harmonisation européenne
est suffisante sur ces sujets-là est
inexistante l'harmonisation elle est
inexistante avons pas de politique déjà
chez nous elle est pas très cohérente
avec les pays de l'Union européenne il y
a de très grandes différences pays du
Sud pays du Nord et nous au
milieu j' j'avais une dernière question
sur ce qui se passe à Dubaï au Maroc en
Algérie où viennent se réfugier les
trafiquants qui ont pignon sur rue qui
se constittuent un patrimoine et selon
vous c'est un sujet absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le
narcotrafic et quelles sont les mesures
que vous pourriez préconiser
bah euh alors l'Algérie et le Maroc ont
des relations complexes avec la France
qui n'est pas le cas de Dubaï ou des
émirats euh avec avec les Émirats il est
possible d'avoir une une relation
directe carrée opérationnelle parce que
ils tiennent
beaucoup de plus en plus d'ailleurs à
leur
réputation dans les autres cas la
question est relève du remord colonial
et elle est extraordinairement
compliquée à traiter pour des tas de
raisons diverses y compris d'histoire du
processus de de de consommation de
constitution des régions internes enfin
il y a il a il y a une histoire
coloniale ancienne et compliquée à
l'intérieur du pays concerné le Maroc
par exemple mais pas seulement et puis
avec l'Algérie encore plus qu'avec le
reste parce que tout est hyp sensible et
que c'est assez compliqué mais eux-mêmes
ont de temps en temps eu des politiques
répressives majeures j'ai noté par
exemple depuis un mois que la Turquie
était passée
d'une comment dire
indolence loc à une répression féroce
contre un très grand nombre de réseaux
de trafiquants de stupéfiants alors pour
des raisons que je ne traiterai pas ici
et et de cette manière-là mais pour des
raisons diverses mais notamment de de
rejet d'une concurrence externe par
rapport à leur organisations criminelles
internes he il n'y a pas que de la bonne
volonté dans cet affaire mais en tout
cas c'est assez impressionnant de voir
le retournement de de tendance et la le
process répressif extrêmement puissant
qui a été entamé en Turquie donc il est
possible de voir la même chose à Dubaï
en tout cas c'est très possible à Abu
Dhabi c'està-dire au niveau central des
émirats à Dubaï ça nécessite un peu un
peu de travail puisque Dubaï est un
opérateur qui ne dispose pas de
ressources naturelles il ne dispose que
du
commerce donc c'est
compliqué de gérer ce type de problème
parce que le réinvestissement et et la
blanchisserie est un sujet qui existe et
qu'on ne peut pas sous estimez voilà
c'est comme expliquer tout d'un coup que
les voitures diesel s subventionné et
l'année d'après que le gazoil c'est mal
voyez ça provoque des réactions un peu
compliquées quand c'est un peu brutal
voilà et ben c'est la même chose dans
les relations
internationales mais ça manque
d'agriculteur à Dubaï alors dernière
question de cette audition
passionnant merci président est-ce qu'on
sait mesurer la prise en main de c'est
mafieux réseau on les appelle comme on
veut peu importe sur l'économie locale
rachat d'entreprise de gré ou de force
et cetera est-ce on sait le mesurer dans
notre pays quand on veut oui quand on
veut quand on fait un groupe local
d'intervention qui fait une enquête
approfondi qui utilise les douanes le
fisque le renseignement l'intelligence
artificielle
Bery le renseignement douanier qui est
très puissant et dont on parle pas
suffisamment et parfois le renseignement
extérieur quand les relations passent
par du crypto et cetera on a des idées
d'imprégnation local local voilà d'un
point de vue global on a des estimations
mais quand on veut vraiment savoir quel
est l'état d'imprégnation du crime
organisé qu'il soit ma stupéfiant
mafieux ou ordinaire entre guillemets
bien
sûr merci beaucoup merci
merci ces échanges pour vos réponses et
l'alimentation de nos réflexions bonne
chance
merci